hey guys this is vidi with max tech and
right here we have Microsoft's brand new
surface laptop 3 as well as Apple's 2019
13-inch base macbook pro both of these
retail at $1300 of course on this model
you've got the all aluminum design I
think you can get a model that's a
little bit cheaper if you get that
alcantara model but this is all aluminum
and I can tell you right now it looks
and feels amazing now at this $1300
price point you do have the option to
choose Alcantara but I'd definitely say
if you're spending $1,300 get the
aluminum model it actually comes with
256 gigs of storage compared to the
MacBook Pro that only comes with 128 and
other than that all the specs are very
very similar there's not much
differences other than the storage so in
this video we're basically going to be
comparing everything that we can between
these two laptops to see which one is
the better Buy and the better value at
the $1300 price point so let's start off
with exterior build quality and design
so as you guys can see this one right
here is all black and this one you've
got the aluminum Space Gray they're both
13-inch laptops but if we take this and
we stack the macbook on top of the
surface 3 you will see that the surface
is actually a little bit bigger
it's definitely taller right here and
it's a little bit wider as well so the
MacBook is going to be more portable and
looking on the side you can definitely
see that the market soft surface is
quite a bit thicker on the back we can
see how nice the aluminum looks on both
of these laptops right here and we can
see vents right up here in the back of
each laptop so that's really nice and
other than that they're very solid the
build quality is super solid on both of
these laptops now comparing the hinges
the MacBook has always been known for
being really easy to open up with just
one finger just like that so let's test
out V Microsoft Surface laptop and would
you look at that now in terms of
authentication the MacBook Pro actually
has touch ID right here in the corner of
the keyboard so you could easily log in
and make purchases whatever you want to
do using your fingerprint but
the Microsoft Surface laptop 3 actually
has Windows hello
right there
so you just open it up it looks at your
face recognizes it unlocks it now I
don't know how secure this is but it's
so much more convenient you don't even
have to put your finger anywhere just
unlocks automatically I really wish that
Apple would implement this into the
MacBook now looking at the overall
layout of these two laptops they look
very similar but there are definitely
some differences first of all you can
tell that you have speaker grilles right
here on the MacBook and they're
completely missing on the surface that's
actually because the speaker's are
underneath the keyboards so we're
definitely gonna have to test out those
speakers and see which ones are better
in just a minute and of course you can
see that the trackpad on the MacBook Pro
is quite a bit larger than the one on
the surface and this is actually not
that small a lot of other Windows
laptops have smaller track pads in this
so overall we're pretty happy with the
size of this trackpad but you definitely
can't beat the size of the one on the
macbook pro as for the keyboard I can
tell that the surface does have it
recessed a little bit deeper into the
laptop itself whereas this just goes
down a little bit and we have like these
rounded keys compared to this
traditional squared off keys and we can
see that the MacBook Pro actually has
the touch bar this year which is really
nice but some don't like it because they
prefer to have a physical Escape key but
I actually don't mind it it's not too
bad you've got all your options right
here and you can customize a lot of it
on this little display right here and
one big difference you can instantly
notice is the difference in the displays
now the surface is actually using a
three by two display compared to a
sixteen by ten so the service is gonna
have more vertical space which is really
nice for browsing the web and things
like that and sixteen by ten actually
isn't bad on the MacBook it's definitely
much better than sixteen by nine on a
lot of Windows laptops so either way
we're really happy with the display
aspect ratios on both of these now
before we get into comparing the
displays let's compare the ports so
right here on the MacBook Pro we get a
headphone jack right there and two
Thunderbolt three ports right here so
one of them could be for charging and
you could use both of these for
connecting monitors EGP use Thunderbolt
three docks all kinds of Thunderbolt
three accessories now on the Microsoft
Surface laptop three we actually have a
max
type connector right here for charging
so if anybody trips over it's just going
to disconnect it's not gonna fall over
which is really nice right here we have
a USB a ports a USB C port and a
headphone jack
now this USB C port actually does not
support Thunderbolt 3 that's actually
one of the biggest pitfalls of this
laptop now that means you can't connect
any GPU a monitor a dock four more ports
you can't do any of that so that's
really really disappointing on this
laptop it's actually surprising that a
$1,300 laptop has Windows hello facial
recognition but doesn't have Thunderbolt
3 at all now comparing the display
quality these both look really great
definitely enough resolution for a
13-inch laptop the only downside with
the surface is that the display is very
reflective so I can definitely see a
massive difference in reflectivity just
waving my hand right here so that could
be a problem for some people and now
let's compare the maximum brightness on
both of these laptops and it looks like
right here on Google's web page it seems
like the surface is actually just as
bright or just slightly brighter than it
is on the MacBook Pro so that's actually
really impressive but in terms of color
accuracy the surface supports 98% of
srgb colors while the MacBook Pro does a
hundred percent and it even goes above
that supporting all the dcpip three
colors well the surface only supports
about 75% of dcpip three so that means
if you want to do very serious photo
editing you definitely want to go with a
MacBook Pro over the surface so with
that out of the way let's compare the
keyboards and the track pads so as you
guys know we have the butterfly keyboard
on the MacBook Pro and a lot of people
complain about the lack of heat travel
and it just feeling like it's very
clicky but just definitely not like the
traditional feel of a keyboard whereas
here on the surface you definitely get
so much more key travel and you get like
that traditional feel very clicky feels
very nice and I'd say if you're used to
a traditional keyboard like this you're
gonna love this laptop whereas it takes
quite a bit of time to get used to the
MacBook Pro I'm already used to it and I
like it I like how it's nice and clicky
I don't mind the low key travel but this
anybody could get used to this keyboard
right here on the surface now Apple is
known for the awesome track pads this is
a force touch trackpad which means you
can actually click anywhere on the
trackpad there is no difference in
clicking feel because it actually
doesn't move there's actually a motor
that vibrates underneath it that
simulates a click so it's even
everywhere and you can actually do a
double click you can do a force click
down for certain things like that
whereas this is more of a diving board
keyboard where it's very stiff and
sturdy at the top and it gets very easy
to click towards the bottom now a lot of
Windows laptops are like this which I
don't really like how that feels
compared to the force touch trackpad but
this is definitely a nicer trackpad than
a lot of the other windows soft ops out
there and now let's get into the speaker
comparison like I said before the
service Ashley has a speaker's under the
keyboard so it might not be the best
situation for sound quality but let's go
ahead and compare it right now let's
start with the surface
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so that was very very interesting
usually Windows laptops do not sound as
loud as MacBook Pros do but right here
you guys just witnessed it it's actually
just as loud or slightly louder now I
did hear some differences the vocals and
the tones were very very clear on the
MacBook Pro and it was very easy to
distinguish the different instruments
whereas on the surface the mids were
pretty loud and it was kind of muffled
and all kind of blended together there
wasn't that much distinction and the
vocals were harder to hear but it was
definitely loud and I'd say these
speakers are very very impressive
compared to a lot of other laptops out
there like the XPS or different brands
like that premium brands so I'm actually
really impressed with the speakers on
the surface and now let's get into the
performance comparison starting out with
Geekbench v alright so we're gonna go
ahead and run the CPU benchmark on both
of these machines so the results are in
and the surface is actually really
impressive we've got a higher single and
multi-core score then on the MacBook Pro
and that's because the surface actually
has a 10th gen ice Lake CPU which is the
latest and greatest technology from
Intel compared to I believe it is 8th
gen still on the base model either way
we were actually really impressed with
the 2019 MacBook Pros jump in
performance from the 2017 base model so
it's actually really impressive on the
surface now getting into Geekbench 5s
graphics test both of these have intel's
iris plus graphics so let's go ahead and
run that test so here are the graphics
results and it's actually really
surprising that the surface got around
38% faster graphics score then on the
MacBook Pro so that's really impressive
so the performance you're getting here
on the surface is quite a bit better
than on the MacBook Pro and finally to
finish off performance I want to test
the disk speed test so I got aja right
here so let's test it on both of these
right here and once again the surface
actually beats out the MacBook Pro you
got a slightly higher read score and
almost double of the write scores and
that's something we usually don't see
because Mac books usually have faster
SSD speeds compared to Windows laptops
so once again Microsoft
job in the performance Department so
with all that said which laptop is the
better bye
of course if you prefer Mac you're
definitely going to go with the MacBook
Pro but if you could go either way
for $1,300 the surface does have more
performance it has more storage
so spec wise the surface actually beats
out the MacBook but when you look at the
fine details like the display quality
the color accuracy the trackpad other
stuff like that the MacBook Pro actually
might be better for professionals who
are trying to do photo editing video
editing or things like that especially
because of the Thunderbolt 3 ports the
lack of Thunderbolt 3 on the surface is
actually a really big downfall of this
laptop so if you're trying to use it
with an e GPU with a monitor with a
thunderbolt ii dock you actually won't
be able to do that on the surface but
other than that if you need a basic
really premium high quality laptop this
is actually a really good option because
the all aluminum build the keyboard the
trackpad the display everything is
actually really decent and very good for
a Windows laptop so of course if you
like Mac this is the way to go because
you still get really good performance
you have excellent display quality you
can use the Thunderbolt 3 with any GPU
monitors everything else so in reality
this is actually one of the toughest
choices of how to make but I'd say
because you get more storage on the
surface and you get such good
performance and everything else is just
so high-quality premium on the surface I
would definitely choose this one over
the MacBook Pro if you don't need
Thunderbolt 3 now if you do need
Thunderbolt 3 it's definitely gonna have
to be the MacBook Pro so I hope you guys
like this comparison definitely click
that circle above to subscribe and check
out some of those other videos right
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]